we just have to see how the rest of the  year is going like I need everybody we  had that sales to push merchandise  probably due to the blizzard in February  we were able to get it back up but we  need to stay strong the date was amazing  she's like a mix of Jennifer Connelly  but cuter if you can oh my god  nevermind he's the cutest puppy jumped  in my lap yesterday when I was in the  lobby is that kind of doggy bug Rick  this is nothing new we were talking  about I'm sorry  hey I got a run real fast but do you  mind emailing Linda and making sure that  she comes tomorrow and brings the cake  and everything yeah thank you my desk  ten minutes okay it's been 30 minutes oh  I'm sorry yeah I was in this analytics  meeting the other day could not  concentrate to save my life  swear I have ADHD I don't know if that's  how that works